So why worry about touch?
Touch events are just click
events on a touch screen, right?
>> No, I don't think they are.
>> Definitely not.
They have different pseudo classes and
different event cycles and
you need to account for both.
Let me show you what can happen if you
don't account for touch events at all.
This is an example site that use touch.
Which you can find the link
in the instructor notes.
I recommend posing this video and
go play with it for a moment.
Pay attention as I'm dragging
this element, what's going on.
Both in depth tools and
on the element itself.
Another good example is here as you
can see I'm just improving my images.
In this example is taking touch,
mouse, and pointer events.
Much better.
Well that was fun.
Notice how the UI didn't
quite react to your touch.
First thing first.
You need to account for
the touch pseudo states.